الان جثتين من احد المباني خلفي ونقلها
الى سياره الاسعاف سنطلب من الزميل المصور
باسل ان يعني يدير الكاميرا الى هذا
المشهد هؤلاء الناس الان يقفون حول
الجثتين التي تم انتشالها وسيتم نقلها في
هذا الاسعاف للاسف يعني ما زالت الجثث
يعني الان ميسون حسب ما فهمت من الزميل
باسل بانه يتم التعرف على الجثث في هذه
الحاله بالفعل الجثث التي يتم انتشالها
يتم يعني جلب الناس او الاقارب الموجودين
والاهالي الموجودين للتعرفوا على الجثث في
حال تم التعرف على الجثث ميسون يتم دفنها
فورا اما الجثث المجهوله الهويه او التي
لا يتم التعرف عليها تبقى لمده 24 ساعه
ومن ثم تؤخذ عينات من الحمض النووي لهذه
الجثث
وتدفن بعد 24 ساعه وتبقى العينات الحمض
النووي حتى يتم التعرف عليها لاحقا
تتحدثين عن الالاف من القتلى وبالتالي لا
يمكن لا يمكن ان ينتظروا اكثر من ذلك
وبالتالي يلجاون الى دفن هذه
الجثث سريع